When I started the keto diet experience leg cramps at night, I researched and saw
that potassium supplementation might help. It seems to, although it seems to,
although I can create leg cramps at will, simply by pointing my leg toes, so
obviously I don't do that normally. Okay, so when a person could kind of create a
leg cramp because you're you're basically tightening your muscles and then they
cramp up. That's typically a side of needing minerals. So if you're tight, if
you tighten up your leg and it goes into a cramp or you're tight, up your foot
in a certain way, it goes into a cramp. Typically that's a side of beads,
deficiencies in some minerals. So taking some minerals can help and
electrolytes like potassium can be very helpful. So yes, taking potassium can
be extremely helpful. So I manage these leg cramps for the most part but I
wonder what you attribute them to as it relates to a ketogenic diet. It really,
if you're not getting a lot of minerals in your ketogenic diet, if you're
staying away from vegetables that have any kind of carbohydrates, you could be
missing the vegetables that have minerals in it. Maybe that's it. I'm not sure
exact. Everybody's definition of a ketogenic diet, what they've chosen to, you
know, the ketogenic diet is a little different. So typically you're not going to
get minerals in any useful complex in meat products and both ketogenic diets are
high in meat products. So maybe that's what you're missing. It's just minerals.